next author Christopher Hitchens
delivers a lecture titled crucibles past
and present
he and author Salman Rushdie chair of
the pen world voices festival have a
conversation following the lecture
Cooper Union in New York City hosts the
hour and 20 minute event hello everybody
thanks for coming I'm Salman Rushdie
thanks and we're here for the closing
event of what I think is being a pretty
good festival the sixth one and the
Arthur Miller lecture is always
something we care a lot about and as as
you'll know we have a bit of bad news
and a bit of good news sad news is that
Sherman Alexie couldn't make it and
we're very sad I mean either personal
reasons and we don't want to go into it
but basically there's a good reason why
it's not here and fortunately for us the
good news is that we were able at very
very short notice to get Christopher
regions to come and do the lecture
instead and
and he is over there and Christopher's
got a talk at his title is obviously
quite relevant to Arthur Miller
crucibles past and present and the way
we're going to do it is that he's going
to talk for about 25-30 minutes then I'm
going to come up here and we're going to
talk for about another 25 30 minutes and
then you know we'd love to throw it open
to you and have you join in as well last
questions of Christopher and like that
so without any further ado Christopher
Hitchens author of God is not great at a
thousand other books here he is
well thank you Salman and take your
ladies and gentleman coming and thank
you to Penn for honoring me twice once
by giving me the abraham lincoln podium
which if anything would encourage one to
abuse i can't think of a more solid
temptation than that and the other is to
be asked to speak in the name of um of
arthur miller and on the the troops with
which those of us in the writing
business will always identify him I
don't consider myself supremely
qualified to talk and say not in his
name but I can say that I knew him a
little that my wife and I were married
by the same rabbi the late Robert
Goldberg who married Arthur Miller to
Marilyn Monroe the same rabbi I'm
flattered also was his character witness
at the same time at the house on
American Activities Committee because it
wasn't enough that Arthur was trying to
get married to the woman considered the
most beautiful in the world he was at
the time having to ask questions about
whether or not he counted as an American
at all and I I can't not tell you just a
couple of things about him and and
Marilyn I just can't so I will I can't
not so I will when she was first
introduced to the Miller family Robert
Goldberg by the way to the end of his
life resisted all efforts to buy from
him her conversion certificate to
Judaism the subject to which she was
fairly new when she met the Miller
family and mr. and mrs. Miller senior
used to feed her thinking she needed a
bit of a flattening up and it often
would begin with matzo ball soup in fact
it would invariably begin that way until
evening when she asked if they ever ate
any other part of the matzo
a contrary to the slightly Hoyt initial
reputation that ms Monroe has had ever
since as clunky residents
she was actually rather demure and
Robert Morris Chaya and the bathroom in
the Miller house was a bit too near the
living room so out of shyness I suppose
you could say Buddha as the French would
put it
she used to him when she retired there
turn on all the taps very loudly just
out of discretion you know you want to
not depress the end of us and after
she'd gone and Matt and Arthur turned to
his mother and said well what do you
think his mother's opinion was very
important to him mrs. Miller senior said
well she's a very nice girl but she sure
pisses like a racehorse well okay I I
had to do that but it's not strictly to
the purpose somebody told me this
evening that it was possible that
attendance was down at today's events
because of a an attempted atrocity in
Times Square last night and if that was
true I would both be depressed and I
would take it as an opportunity to
underline what I wanted to talk about in
the case of mr. Miller and in the topic
I picked which was crucibles present and
past which is to say the contagion of
fear as the United States thawed out in
the 1950s it's it's incredibly easy is
depressingly easy shall one say to get
people who are the children of a
revolution who are born into a country
that is governed by a constitution with
all the rights and privileges of a free
society it's very very easy to get
people to give that up or to devalue it
or to panic and abandon the values of
that Constitution in particular of its
amendments it's wonderful amendments
that constitute the Bill of Rights and
the reason why Arthur Miller was so
important to us and remains important I
think the people who don't remember any
of it is that he was one of the very few
Americans who would say no I'm not going
to go along with this and made out of it
a famous play
calling an early in time before the
founding of the Republic before the
proclamation and promulgation of the
Constitution when there was an era of
witch hunting which is another way of
saying clerical or religious panic
persecution tyranny and hysteria to see
under what conditions we who look down
on the poor old primitive uneducated
settlers of the Bay Colony and what
conditions were entitled to do that what
gives us the right to condescend to
people if we aren't sure in our own
minds that we would be able in the same
conditions to resist I think it's a fair
bet than anyone who takes the trouble to
buy a ticket to a pan event has played
this game in their head at some point in
their life how would I shape up what
would I do when the neighbors were being
shipped onto the trains or maybe when
because that so often comes when it's
too late you think maybe I should have
done something before they started
putting them on the trains when should I
have started would it have been with the
censorship would it have been with the
racism would have been with the
off-the-record imprisonments and
executions at what point I feel sure I
would have taken a stand at some point I
would have been brave we all we all have
had to do this and we've all had to look
at society's contemporary to ours and in
the past and asked well ok what when the
Fugitive Slave Act is still on the books
and has been extended to the states of
the north as well what about it where
the slave catchers cross over into
Pennsylvania and come as far as New York
and there's a bounty out and there's a
lot of pressure to bail or of course i'm
get a shelter this one should go in my
house aren't i everyone thinks that they
would everyone has a it's a pleasurable
imagination until you begin to doubt
yourself until you begin to think i
wonder if i would be that good there's a
wonderful poem by Edna st. Vincent
Millay it's called conscientious
objector I can't quote it all but it
begins it's just come back to me but it
begins some I shall die but that is all
that I shall do for death I owe him
nothing he's mounting up in the yard
today his horse his hooves the
clattering he has business in Cuba but
I will not give him a leg up I will not
tell him where the black boy lies in the
swamp I shall die but that is all that I
shall do for death well this is a hard
test of people to pass and by the time
I'd got to know Arthur Miller he was of
course quite old but he'd he'd continued
to witness throughout his life the many
decades I remembered when I was at the
nation magazine publishing an
extraordinary article helping to publish
a very humorous account he gave of going
to a dinner at the American Embassy in
Turkey at the head of a pen delegation
which included himself and Harold Pinter
and how Harold Pinter had given the
American ambassador Turkey an absolutely
ruinous time throughout the dinner all
night because of turkeys treatment of
the of its Kurdish minority and I had my
differences with help enter and in
federate had my differences with that
same American ambassador and I could
almost feel sorry for ambassador starts
who pay and having to face Miller and
Pinter for an evening
knowing the American policy was
complicit in a near genocidal policy in
southeastern Anatolia and you know you
could have let that go you could have
said we're here on a delegation of
writers it's nice of the ambassador
hello dinner we can sit this one out no
you can't no this is your chance you'll
always be sorry later if you kept quiet
there's never a good occasion for
keeping your mouth shut
so so far nothing but praise for Arthur
from me but there came a time when a
good friend of mine and a great friend
of the cause of writing and a free
expression and of writers and people who
would either sacrifice free expression
Salman Rushdie was hit as your of will
remember by the clerical dictator of the
theocratic dictator of foreign state
with a fatwa that's the way the word
entered our language that condemned him
Salman to birth a life sentence and a
death sentence it condemned him to death
and he enjoined all Muslims in the world
to bring it about which meant that
Salman had to alter his social life and
other arrangements quite radically for a
bit and well I remember thinking on that
day which was the 14th of February 1989
well for me for my lot for us this is
the case this is the chest we
and wondered what would it be in our
generation most free speech cases you'll
find if you look into them from the from
the trial of Socrates onwards have been
to do with blasphemy
Socrates Galileo Spinoza you can fill in
blanks feel so almost always that
someone is accused to have gone too far
this time and to have outraged the
sensibilities of the community as well
as the laws and codes of the state and
the city and profaned the gods which you
really can't have because then where
would we be how would we know how to
behave if it wasn't for a celestial
dictatorship we wouldn't know right from
wrong without that so it's a really
subversive thing to be doing I thought
well that's pretty easy but we should do
better perhaps than just get the usual
suspects to sign the usual free speech
petition maybe we should all say since
the fatwa applies explicitly applies to
all those responsible publication of the
book but missing codasyl is often not
mentioned we should all sign a petition
saying we consider ourselves co
responsible on the model of Spartacus
or the Danish volunteers in the Nazi
occupation who said if the Jews image
wear yellow star will wear one too and
they can't get us all so I thought it's
good idea just upped the ante a bit and
then Susan Sontag who too much also
would like to dedicate any value to you
that these remarks may presents and to
her memory who was that year's president
of Penn fortunately it came the horrible
news that a lot of people were strangely
reluctant to sign that the fear factor
the feeling of the Ayatollah Khomeini's
arm could reach that far the death
squads wrong the prowl that anyone who
got too closely identified with this
might themselves become the object
overhead was actually keeping away some
people from the meeting we plan to have
to read from someone's book and keeping
their names off the list they said no I
don't want to sign and I tell this story
in my upcoming memoir I don't I didn't
want to say anything at all Jolanda mine
the memory of Arthur but there was a
crisis with him and he said you know
what you probably don't need me
after all I'm Jewish it would really
attract attention it would change the
subject
it's amazing how persuasive fear can be
you can always think of a good reason
I'll behave better next time maybe this
isn't such a crux after all and I
remember thinking this really is for me
a moral and intellectual and personal
crisis because if the author of The
Crucible has decided that he this is an
appointment he's reluctant to keep then
we're all in very grave trouble but of
course the story has a happy ending and
Arthur came through very well as did a
number of other people who'd hesitated
but I'll never forget that week and how
and what I learned about how fragile how
tenuous the commitment of the society to
its basic values often is and how easy
it is to panic people into betraying
them and I'll stay with this trope if
you don't mind because I think it's back
and I think the rot is spreading and I
think it began this present phrase about
exactly five years ago when a small
newspaper in the Jutland area of Denmark
called you lands poster
published some you'll know about this
and cartoons better to say caricatures
actually of the figure of the Prophet
Mohammed who is wrongly thought cannot
ever be represented in art of several
Islamic representations of him
particularly in Persian culture probably
enough it's not it's not a prohibition
there was of any great value or any
great force though it's believed to be
by people who like to find cultural
reasons as they often do for political
cowardice and moral cowardice at any
rate you know the sequel there was an
organized attempt to destroy the Danish
economy by boycott coordinated by some
very extreme rulers in Denmark with some
partners of theirs in other countries
there was an open season on Danish
people many of whom were attacked in
other countries by the end of it we
think at least 300 people were killed
and not all of them Danish in different
countries though riots between Muslims
and Christians in Nigeria in countries
which when demonstrations are never
normally allowed at all and where the
police control everything such as Syria
large crowds were allowed to burn down
the Danish Embassy without any apparent
police intervention if the thing had the
every appearance of a horrible
orchestration I thought well here again
what could be a clearer case here is a
small Scandinavian democracy which had a
very heroic record of resistance to
Nazism its citizens are peaceful its
government is not allowed by law to
censor the press the demand was that the
government closed that paper and and
apologized for its publication Danish
prime minister said I can't do that I
have no right in law to effect the
publication of cartoons or articles in
Denmark but at least the Friends of
Denmark will show their faces now and
we'll have a proper discussion about
this full-frontal challenge to the
values of the First Amendment can't wait
to see for example what the State
Department will say the Bush State
Department here's here's a chance for it
to really stick out his chest and that
testify for real values well the Bush
State Department made a statement saying
we're very sorry about any offence
caused by the Danish cartoons now we
don't keep a State Department going to
comment on the internal affairs of
Danish journalism the State Department
could reasonably have said that wasn't
its job its job is to say we stand by
our Democratic allies and we
particularly feel Paul that the
violation of its diplomatic immunity and
the sovereign protection of its
government couldn't even go that far
the first thing was to apologize well
that's bad but I I'm not a diplomat and
I live in Washington but I'm not a
politician I'm a journalist that a world
my profession my great profession will
stick up on this point we'll have a
proper discussion and the first thing is
to show the cartoons because people must
see what the fuss is about
I mean if we don't live now in the age
of the image where do we live everything
is image driven newspapers magazines and
of course the television everything is
to do with the the pictures themselves
lips Asuma not one outlet in the United
States will publish or show those
cartoons not one network not one
national newspaper not one news magazine
I couldn't even get the monster in my
column in sleep which is online though
you could in the air
go by link to find them but the magazine
itself wouldn't take responsibility to
do it a small magazine I work for
skeptical it's called the skeptical
Inquirer
um secular magazine the church is not
called septum it was called free inquiry
pardon me the to my wife free inquiry
pub did publish them I don't know of
circulation is even in five figures but
the bookstore chains immediately pulled
all copies of our magazine from the
shelves and this was in response to no
threat it was in response to no pressure
it was in response to no danger at all
as when I was a kid we would say was
crying before you were hurt but I
thought then and I think now it was a
terrible capitulation there wasn't
anyone in the United States who would
say look first order of business let's
see what the fuss is about what do these
pictures really look like no one would
take that responsibility and nobody said
it was for any other reason than fear I
know these people I know these editors I
work for some of them why didn't you do
it what we afraid of we were afraid of
reprisal well of what value is your
First Amendment what value is the
enormous money that you make out of free
expression the the giant revenues that
are be to be made in the country that
enjoys the right of free publication if
it won't be defended at the very first
challenge you think you can't get worse
yes it can
Yale University Press which is run by
someone used to be a publisher of mine
but won't ever be again called John
Donna Church decides to commission a
book by Danish scholar on the Danish
cartoons to learn its subject sorry I
learned in treatment of the subject
including the vexed question of is there
permissible representation of the
Prophet Muhammad in Islamic art nicely
produced book comes out Yale University
Press the University of Nathan Hale the
man who said give me liberty or give me
death and then at the last minute they
decide to cut out all the illustrations
in the book all of them not just the
cartoons no illustration of any kind
Yale University Press without a shot
being fired and says no we're not going
to do it we don't have the guts for it
they even issued a statement saying that
they felt if they did do so they would
be instigating violence now another
thing that depressed me at that point
a separate question is it's a pity that
the University Press of a great
University the proof readers don't know
the meaning of the word instigate to
instigate something is to try and make
it happen is to make its it's equivalent
to saying incitement it's saying you are
you're trying to stir something up it is
your aim that the be violence if you
instigate it in the in the passive use
of the word they made themselves
responsible for any action taken of a
criminal nature criminally violent
nature by the publication of the book
which was which has two bad effects one
it runs away and it deprives the readers
as well as the author of the book of the
right to discuss the matter freely and
second in advance it excuses the
criminal activity because after all it
can't be their fault it's ours for
showing the pictures it's ours for
printing the book it's ours for having
Salman as an author in our midst it's
our fault and so there's an indemnity
given in advance to the men of violence
that's there for a double insult if you
like to the principles of civilization
and it goes on you'll probably remember
on New Year's Eve we were preoccupied at
that point by the circle Christmas
bomber who nearly brought down the full
civilian aircraft from Amsterdam over
the city of Detroit but a few nights
later on New Year's Eve one of the
authors of one of those cartoons a man
called Kirk Westgard 79 year old man who
is having a sleepover with his
granddaughter in Copenhagen one of the
quietest calmest sweetest chance you can
ever hope to see has his jaw broken in
with an axe by a wanted Somali gangster
who's come to kill him in his
granddaughter with an axe on New Year's
Eve and if he hadn't managed to lock
himself in the bathroom and press a
panic button they'd both be dead and mr.
Westergard you'll be interested to hear
has since been let go by his magazine as
someone who it's too much trouble to
keep on the staff it's it's just I was
just having a couple of weeks ago he's
it's some it's all very well to stick
off a free speech but you know there are
limits and you can't
someone embarrassing you were having his
granddaughter and himself attacked on
New Year's Eve it gets around you look
bad you think it couldn't happen here
well I've already told you it could and
has with the cartoon case and then hope
it would have escaped your attention
that last week the the channel on
American television that above all
prides itself on saying that the answer
to the question is nothing sacred is
always know where there's no there is no
cow that cannot be smacked around and
abused Comedy Central decided that
discretion was by far the better part of
value of fella and of all things to get
to cave in on and of all the examples we
can set to the smart and wised up
American youth who liked to watch in
South Park is told you can't make a
teddy bear joke involving the Prophet
Mohammed and as soon irreverence central
no-holds-barred central gives in without
a fight or let's say not without a fight
let's give them some credit there is one
nutcase who has one web site in New York
who posted a picture on his web site of
what happened to Theo van Gogh the Dutch
filmmaker who made a film about the
oppression of Muslim women in the city
of Amsterdam and who was ritually
murdered in the street having his shot
off his bicycle he was gutted like a
sheep in the roadway and a knife plunged
into his heart which held attached to it
a letter an open letter to another good
friend of mine miss ayaan Hirsi Ali
who's wonderful new book Nomad is about
to be published telling her as an
elected member of the Dutch parliament
and a refugee from Somalia and from
genital mutilation and from forced
marriage and from sectarian warfare and
religious theocratic oppression that she
was next and she now lives in this
country and I can't even tell you where
anymore because she too like so many of
my friends now in Europe and United
States has to go around with a permanent
poly God whereas the people who put Theo
van Gogh's picture on their web site and
say to the makers of Comedy Central this
is going to happen
- you sign revolution Muslim calm don't
appear to feel any kind of fear at all
they seem to feel as perhaps they are
that the First Amendment protects them -
well if it does and if this great
architecture of free speech if this this
constitutional roof under which we've
all been thriving so proudly for so long
is to mean anything then we're going to
have to say revolution calm cannot close
down an American cable channel at whim
by making a little bit of a threat so
the question comes right back to where I
suppose I initiated it which is it's no
longer a hypothetical one you're not
being asked what would you do when the
climate of fear began to spread and when
even people you thought to be reliable
and brave will remember urgent
appointments elsewhere and say well
perhaps this particular meeting I could
skip or maybe that petition isn't so
vitally important after all I've signed
so many petitions in my time I can miss
one and anyway captain Alfred Dreyfus
always looked a bit of a seedy character
to me rather suspicious-looking type you
know maybe we should pick our fights
with more care you can feel the air the
atmosphere thickening with excuses and
with euphemisms no question is what are
you going to do about this what are you
going to do about now if if what I was
just told us to the ranks of this very
Hall this evening were thinned not by
the prospect of having myself instead of
Sherman Alexie forbidding enough as it
is but by a fizzle but I have fizzled
nothing of a bomb in in Times Square
look look you are the children of a
revolution the United States did have to
go through a great deal to erect this
architecture of constitutional freedom
and protection people in living memory
died to register to vote to be able to
hold a public meeting to be able to
assert their most basic and elementary
rights and we celebrate them every year
and we all wish we could have been there
and we weren't but we can be because
there'll always be a time a rendezvous
with this question and everyone's going
to measure themselves as are familiar
did by how they shape up to it so I can
now if
haven't made my point by now not going
to have made it am i and I think I've
probably about trespassed on the point
where Simon and I were going to talk and
then we'll you can be our prisoners for
a bit longer and then we'll be your
hostage and so this would be the moment
perhaps to invite back on the stage
someone who has witnessed for this I
wanted to just I've just got a what a in
some random way respond to a few of the
things you said we can let's talk about
the cartoons a bit more because it seems
to me that there's two separate issues
about things like the Danish cartoons
which get conflated one is the question
about should the cartoons have been
published in the first place now seems
to me any newspaper editor anybody on a
picture desk of a newspaper or a
magazine every day is presented with
material where they have to make the
decision is this worth putting in the
magazine or not and I think we can also
agree that maybe no two picture editors
would make the same decisions some of
them would print all those things on the
print one or two something written on
them so on the one hand you've got the
argument about quality and so on should
the things be in the paper I mean myself
I think that most of them were rather
tedious and the ones that weren't were
actually the most offensive ones I mean
the best cartoon was the one which shows
suicide bombers arriving at the pearly
gates yes to be greeted by the Prophet
Mohammed saying would you please stop
doing it because we're running out of
virgins
yes that has them that has the great
marriage and being funny that has he has
a bit of bite to it now
yeah and actually the one with the
turban the bomb in determine was
similarly you know the perfectly
legitimate strong satirical point and
well drawn and well drawn yeah that's a
those two the ones that people got most
exercised about it would actually be the
ones that I would if I was a picture
editor that I would have published and
many of the others were just beyond
bland so that's one issue would you do
it would you not do it but it seems to
me that there's that the second issue is
what which is what you were talking
about I think is what happens when the
subject of violence arises and at that
point it seems to be the subject changes
the subject is no longer about whether
you should publish or not publish these
things but about how do you respond to
violence yes you respond to it with
cowardice or courage and at that point
it seems to me that every newspaper in
the world should publish the Danish
cartoons not because they like that when
not actually because they particularly
want to insult Islam but just to make
the point that you don't give in to
threats yes and so I think sometimes you
know when people start talking about the
cartoons as objects they you know where
they good or bad where they offensive or
inoffensive it's that's one half of the
point but the second half the point is
the question of the response to violence
you know and I think that's that's one
of the things that has got very blurred
recently well should I should I come in
here
well first you know what happens to
Mohammed after when he blows himself up
and arrives at the pearly gates you
don't know leaves told okay welcome
let's see who don't you know is mr.
Thomas Jefferson excellent here's mr.
James Madison takes his hand have you
met mr. George Mason trades his hand mr.
Patrick Henry okay Patrick hey what is
this he said what he did ask for 72
Virginians
there's actually thing there's even a
better thing I was afraid this might
happen
see this is I'm now not kidding serious
Islamic scholarship has recently
suggested that the 72 virgins was a
mistranslation of the original and then
what was actually supposed to greet
people
on their arrival as martyrs was 72
raisins raisins or white grapes you know
there's a very good there's a serial
Aramaic mistranslation of the Koran that
just a few done a lot of damage I think
one of the few good reasons for
believing in the afterlife
yes is wanting to see the faces of yoga
that I accompanied arriving at heaven to
be handed a bowl of raisins it also adds
to the strong case for saying that holy
books are in fact man-made and not
dictated by God wishes I think the part
of this discussion look remember the
origin of the Danish question was this
it was proposed in Denmark which was
doing his level best as many societies
have to make Muslims feel welcome in
Danish society it was thought the world
school children should learn about Islam
we can have a book for kids cartoon book
you know all you need to know Islam for
beginners kind of thing but they
couldn't get any cartoonists children's
cartoonists to do it as they were afraid
of making a mistake yes
upsetting someone so it was to satirize
this reticence and this fear that
flaming rose my friend the editor of
Iran's person said all right let's have
a cartoonist competition and we'll see
if we can represent the Prophet so it
begins with this reticence the second
thing is you're right of course that
people should do it out of solidarity
and you'll write of course that it's a
judgment call in point of taste in the
first instance but once it's become a
matter of violence and controversy
there's a second stage which you have to
report it yes you know I wish everybody
did on the front page except they
reported it without the content yeah
let's do it without the picture I can't
really think of a parallel of what I
mean they would say well
Picasso has gone too far with Guernica
you know he's taken a obviously
propagandistic attitude towards the
Spanish Civil War there's a huge rabbit
that's painting
you'd be very interested to know more
about it but unfortunately can't show
you what it looks like because that
would be inviting reprisal from Franco
or something I can't think of a collie
vervet but even worse now was everything
his image
everything is imminent one of the most I
think mealy-mouthed pieces of language
that has developed to justify this kind
of behavior is a kind of reinvention of
the meaning of the word respect it it
seemed to me when I was growing up that
respect meant that you took people
seriously it didn't mean that you never
disagree with them you know to respect
someone is to say okay we'll take on
what you have to say and if I don't
agree with it I will offer a
counter-argument the idea that it would
be disrespectful to someone to in any
way disagree from their system of belief
is a new ideas a new meaning of the term
respect and it seems to me to have
nothing to do with respect and what it
actually means is I'm too afraid to do
it so what you have is cowardice
masquerading as disrespect and that's
become more and more and more common
very clear in the case of the of the
cartoons because I think the point you
made which needs to be said a great deal
is that is that blasphemy the the
refusal to accept the church as the
limiting point on thought is something
which throughout human history has been
the thing that has moved the human race
forward when you mentioned Galileo and
Socrates the one should also remind
people that the trial of Jesus Christ
was a possibly trial sure works so an ad
from those three you could say you have
you know Western religious belief
Western scientific understanding and
Western philosophy
they all emerge from blasphemy cases
yeah he was asking for trouble by saying
it was the Son of God
yes yes he knew what he was doing as
they say meaningfully about you I revere
I remember that I will always was abused
or not amused it wasn't funny at the
time when people said that about me that
I knew what I was doing it would be
really strange I thought to spend five
years writing a novel and not know what
you were doing what would that be that
act but then another thought there which
I mentioned Trude earlier you were
raised Muslim yeah well you can be
accused of apostasy I know except my
parents were about as much live as a
two-door fingernail but I've always
thought that the great gift my parents
gave me was to not be religious
they still excused me religion no I
that's true but in the eyes of the madam
yes Omar you belong like justice that's
what is a lapsed Catholic you can't
leave the church unless you're
excommunicated you know if I'd been
called your Harvey Weinstein there would
have been no further well there wouldn't
have been maybe that shoulda be
that's another question yes that she
does a very tempting but no never mind
that's not good with with you with you
and ayaan Hirsi Ali and with Chaz Newman
as mean and many others there's the
question of apostasy which Muslims can
if they like claimed as their internal
affair what's interesting now with
Denmark is a new light and Comedy
Central and a couple of other events in
London is that lines being crossed now
you don't have to be a Muslim to be
brought within the range no of reprisal
I remember quite soon after the attack
of the Satanic Verses being sent by a
fan a t-shirt on which was the legend
blasphemy as a victimless crime
which you think about it and then you
realize that it's completely in line
with with your with with God is not
great because of course it's God who is
the victim who doesn't exist yes oh man
rather wounding Lee said of my title
that it was knowingly one word too long
it just circumcised one word and you've
got the truth um I wanted to ask you a
couple of things not I mean I think yes
this is we should come back to this of
it but it seemed to me one of the things
that to people of our generation
it's very strange I think is the
recrudescence of religion as a political
force because when we were kids in the
60s there were many things that were up
there that we needed to fight against it
I don't think it ever occurred to us
that the power of religion whatever
religion would once again be the thing
we had to battle we actually thought
that that battle was won and it turns
out that we were wrong and I wanted to
ask you why you think that is what is it
you know one of the things that Andre
Malraux supposed to have said 'no parity
did not say is that the 21st century
will be the century of religion
apparently he didn't say that but it
seems so far on the basis of ten years
to be the case
and i wonder why you think it is that
this battle that we all thought was over
has returned to become the central
battle of our time well Lenin apparently
really did say he thought the last
battle would be between communism and
Islam partly because Islam was a
competitor in the third world against
imperialism
which in some ways it can restore
represent itself as being so I think
that a proximate cause not an exact one
but a proximate cause would be a
contributing cause probably is the
collapse of communism not least in the
Soviet Union itself or rather in Formula
so their territory itself work now for
example the russian orthodox church the
old patron of serfdom and Czar ISM and
naughty Semitism is now fully back in a
very dangerous nationalist form
it's the clerical bodyguard to Putin's
regime it has special privileges within
the state the army and elsewhere and
over all other faiths in Russia
that's a by the way I think it will be a
very dangerous thing as Russian
chauvinism and revulsion gets more
increased we have a tremendous revival
of the forces of reaction in the Roman
Catholic Church exemplified by this very
squalid Bavarian
bureaucrat is the current Pope whose
first act as Pope was to readmit to the
church those who'd been excommunicated
for denying the Holocaust and so to
rebuild the complete the hard right wing
element of Catholicism that basically
thought Vatican 2 was a mistake
so refund mentalizing what they still
think of is the one true church then you
have the crazy settlers in in occupied
territories in Palestine you think that
they can bring on the Messiah by
stealing Arab land and then you have the
Christians who say wouldn't that be a
great idea we support the Jews as the
Rope supports the hanging man they bring
on the apocalypse we get Jesus back a
lot of people in this country and trying
still to maintain that this goes on - I
wouldn't have believed it that American
children should be taught garbage with
equal time no now girls and boys after
the chemistry practice will have alchemy
break
it's enough to make a cat laugh isn't it
but they never stop in Texas and also
big book scoobo producing areas that
this nonsense
is it is unstoppable I remember at the
time that that the state of Kansas
decided that intelligent design had to
be taught at the same level as as that
straight vaguely unproved theory called
Darwinism it actually I wrote a piece of
which it's suggested that this decision
by the state of Kansas showed that
Darwin was wrong because it because it
showed that natural selection did not
always choose logistics
survive oh yeah sometimes the unfit just
survived and that it was actually
possible for the human race to regress
as well as progress so there was a
wonderful in Alabama I remember there
was a public servant who said that we
couldn't be sure about the truth of the
theory about the big bang because nobody
was there at the time yes yes but the
equal time demand I think is a an
excellent one because there are now a
very large number of churches who take
this view who are in support sorry in
receipt of grants from the so called
faith-based initiative which I'm sorry
to say President Obama hasn't canceled
or otherwise in receipt of a tax break
and say it seems to me very clear we
should take them up on equal time say
we'll teach your stuff in the schools at
least once a week and they're not in the
science class but in the social studies
bed and you have to sell and teach
Darwin material 50% of the time in your
church well you know just depressing
that will be the law and see how they
like a little of that seems to me even
if you just look at the United States if
you look at the politics of the post-war
period if you look at the the Eisenhower
election even even the kennedy election
so that it wasn't so necessary for
religion to be a subject in the election
nowadays it seems to me you can't be
elected dog catcher in America unless
you talk about your deep belief in
such-and-such church why do you think it
is that there's so much greater cause of
religious discourse in this country I
actually think that that's only true if
you and everyone else keeps saying so
hmm
I mean the number of people who snore of
the above for religion in the country
has doubled in the last year also the
last year the last five years to
something like 16 17 percent I think
it's probably higher the number of
people who check the box and say I am
about to store a Michalik I know because
I go into Bayesian their church is full
of crisis and uncertainty that it
doesn't reflect a monolithic rugosity at
all Barack Obama got elected while
having to discern the only church he
be near he'd taken so little care to
pick one that it nearly got him
unelected the church he went to since
hasn't been to a church at all and ended
his inauguration speech which I attended
with a very good quotation from Thomas
Paine so I'm not sure at all if you give
a person of reasonable integrity and
honesty and and presenta bility let's
say was able to face the election and
say I personally don't attend a church
and don't have a belief I think there's
every reason to think they could win
well I hope you're right the political
right in this country clearly thinks
that the religious card is well worth
playing
yes but the Christian Right have had a
very thin time lately and the Catholic
right as well
I mean who who really now thinks that
the Catholic Church has any moral right
to tell a politician that they'll be
denied the sacraments if they don't
conform I mean I'd like to see them try
it again I really do would like to see
that well that would wants to be in a
very dreadful threat to move it outside
this country one of them let me just ask
you given the you know the Huntington
thesis all these ideas that Clash of
Civilizations
what do you think do you think these are
was a religion or are they was as many
wars of religion have done Wars which
use religion as a cloak for other
discontents well I'm sure it's both and
there's a lot of the latter I mean
remember that the Crusades which the
Muslim world goes on about a lot and
quite understandably began with a huge
program against European Jewry then
would they move in estat nearly finished
it they moved across the Bosphorus or
not cross but to the Bosphorus and
destroyed Byzantine Orthodox Eastern
Orthodox Christianity which they thought
of as a as a heresy and an anatomist so
before they even got to Jerusalem and
started butchering the Muslims they'd
they've settled accounts with the Jews
and with the only other papacy the only
other Christian rival excuse me in the
picture - I think so Steven Runciman is
probably quite right to say that at that
point the Crusades were the most
retarding experience of human
civilization had ever undergone and
we're still we're still suffering from
the consequences it was an intra
Christian war that led to the
said likewise as you can see in Iraq and
elsewhere there's at least one civil war
within Islam between the Sunni and the
Shia against our Margy Muslims for
example are considered heretical
especially in Pakistan against the
Sufism it's becoming a warlord religion
almost Islam because they're a dueling
fad was issued by separate authorities
unluckily for them in some ways and for
us they don't have a pope who can put a
unified line everyone has to follow the
various centers of power and often they
want to settle these disputes on
non-muslim soil yeah I mean after all no
Sunni government ever supported the fact
were against you I think on students in
Austria well I mean it was no government
at all actually other than other than
that of Iran right and and that was
partly for political reasons because
actually when the protests against the
Satanic Verses began they were largely
financed by Saudi Arabia and the Iranian
Authority hijacked yes I saw the
campaign thus enormously pissing off
Saudi Arabia and is one of the reasons
no one outbids the Ayatollah yeah no
well I mean I just would like to point
out in regard to me and the Ayatollah
Khomeini that you know one of us is dead
yes
do not mess with novelties literal
literal scripture monitor the written
word will remain um
and it's true that if you look at the
the muslim world the political apart
from the sydney she a split the
political dissensions are so profound
that it's very difficult to speak of a
jihad yes you know you but the afghans
hate the iranians who hate the saudis
who hate the syrians and so on so that
it's it's clearly not unified but on the
other hand there clearly has grown up
something which is of appeal to it may
be a small group but as but a dangerous
group where the idea of the the pan
global jihad has become very attracted
yes and what do you think that's much I
mean it's very noticeable for example of
the I shouldn't prejudge their case but
I didn't like the look of it the four
Pakistani boys who left a suburb of my
hometown the other day and turned up in
the wrong camp in Pakistan are only the
latest in a large number of young men
from England from France elsewhere
who've volunteered to go die in remote
parts the Muslim world now it's
interesting isn't it it always has to be
they want to go work with our Qaeda or
the Taliban
why wouldn't a young Muslim in in London
before 2001 I want you to go and fight
with the Northern Alliance in
Afghanistan which as a Muslim and
organization as could be had fought
against the Soviet Union was opposed to
the Taliban had probably had more
support than it did no one dares to
volunteer for that no one went to
volunteer for the Kurdish people who
were fighting against Saddam Hussein
just as Muslim all the all the Muslim
activists took the side of Saddam
Hussein when it came to the crunch in
the war who was who himself enjoyed the
support of al-qaeda if not in a military
operational sense he had the sympathy of
their proclamations in some horrible way
it's thought that your uncle
or any other kind of Muslim yeah the
authentic stuff has to be the most
horrible the most extreme and the most
completely consecrated to violence that
that consecration being sealed by
self-destruction suicide so that it
really is a battle for what you could
call the soul on Islam I sometimes think
I wondered what you think about this
that in the way that Soviet Communism
soviet-style communism kind of burned
through a large part of the world and
then burned out there's an argument
which says that in those countries where
radical Islam has become most powerful
it is also most disliked that's to say
you know the people of Afghanistan a
very large majority of them do not like
to talk about a very large majority of
the population of Iran does not like the
rule of the items the people of Algeria
who flirted with the feasts of the GI a
very rapidly moved away from them so
it's a rock mmm Iraq is totally isolated
the al-qaeda so so here's an argument
which is that here is a years and
rhetoric which appears to be very
attractive kind of sexy glamorous
particularly to young men particularly
young men without much hope of the
future and it can burn into a society
with great speed but then very rapidly
people come to decide to discover that
they hate it yes so what do you think of
that idea that this may be a short-lived
phenomena by the way I think you're
obviously right community there's every
sign of a turn of that kind among the
people of Somalia now as well against
the so called Shabaab many of whom are
foreign volunteers quite a lot of them
Americans and yes no one who's ever
tried it once wants to try to gain
that's absolutely true but it's a lot to
go through and it can vary I mean this
Afghanistan will take a long long time
to recover yeah just for a very brief
period of of Taliban rule it's not that
difficult to diagnose are they natural
if you forbid yourself the talents of 50
Center the population to start with as
before we do anything else their new
band music then you ban all books that
arm the Koran the floor is going to keep
on dropping well it takes a long time to
bring it back up to where it was
if you mean might we just let them burn
themselves out a note that you were
saying it must calluses that but not if
you think well could we sit it out and
so I mean I think perhaps not because
the damage done is so great and the
problem with it as with all theocracies
is it doesn't have a soft critical
capacity if they look around and they
notice okay all the children's teeth are
falling out nothing works here except
the secret police in the fields nothing
really grows except footprints what have
we been doing wrong what they'll say is
we have any doing anything wrong we just
maybe haven't been preying on enough and
in the meantime the Crusaders i honest
conspiracy has been at work to subvert
our country yeah so of the huge number
of failed and unemployed and
unemployable young men they've got they
try to export them they explore the
violence back to the worst so that we
have every interest in not just stopping
the jihadist element but is stopping the
terrible under development that Islamism
brings I mean just to say this way very
often you read people quite smart people
saying well these people are the
products of poverty and unemployment so
you heard it no they're not they're the
cause of poverty and unemployment no
Society they've ever had any control
over has not been immediately more poor
and with much less employment the
national income of Indonesia was reduced
by a whole point by the attacks of
al-qaeda on Bali for example they drove
many people into poverty nine o'clock
that's their plan
don't fool yourself that it's a protest
against bad conditions it's a wish for
them at the height of the Soviet Union a
lot of non soviet socialist voices in
europe and america around the world made
a distinction between what they saw as
the
distortions of the Soviet system and
what they called actually existing with
the what they call actually existing
communism which was clearly cruel and
despotic and you know so on and so on
and if you like true socialism yes the
true Church of Karl Marx which was
virtuous it see it seems me now that
there's often a similar argument being
made people who wish to distinct
distinguish themselves from you know
actually existing Islam which is cruel
and despotic in many of its national
manifestations and the separate idea of
the true faith which is you know
religion of peace of love
and and I wondered what you thought
about that well I was one of those on
the Left who spent a lot of time with
the with the Left Opposition in Eastern
Europe people who did take a form of
that critique mmm who would who were not
in favor of nature or capitalism people
like I suppose in Poland Adam Michnik
would have been one who not Harville but
some of the Czech opposition were
Democrat socialists of one kind or
another yeah and in Yugoslavia too and
in Bosnia particularly so and I still
have some sympathy for that that
critique the thing about that is it's
it's a bit more testable objectively I
mean if you come to the conclusion
actually there is something wrong with
the pricing policy of a socialist
economy it has of all things real
difficulty working out what the value of
things ought to be and this probably
isn't a result of it being hijacked
it may be a false happiness here does
you don't think you're going to go to
hell for saying that say well you don't
have to bring upon yourself quite the
same condemnation
the thing about theocracy is that it
tends to say that if anything goes wrong
if a system breaks down it is only
because we haven't tried it hard enough
yeah thus for example I I go on about
this all the time we should be thinking
about our Iranian brothers and sisters
every day not just the struggle they're
having to bring about a democracy and
the fact that the Revolutionary Guards
who've taken over their country are also
the people who control the nuclear
weapons but they're on top of the
Iran is booked to have a terrible
seismic catastrophe it's coming like a
heart attack to Tehran and no one's
doing anything to earth create
earthquake proof the country at all
nothing nothing like what the Chileans
have done even is more like Asia and at
Friday prayers I knew this would happen
Friday prayers I've been writing about
it for weeks the Friday prayers the week
before last the guy did discuss
possibilities necessary over the
earthquake coming being quite bad news
which by the way it will be if there are
underground nuclear facilities that no
one knows about and he said well of
course there'll be an earthquake because
women insist on uncovering their faces
yes the promiscuity Wiz was the official
sermon of Friday in turn the sexuality
of women is the cause of the earth yawns
now both of us both of us have suffered
from précisément both of us have
suffered from the seismic effects of the
female sex
speak for yourself and we know it can't
be we know it can't be underestimated
it's a it can move mountains all right
this is ridiculous but they know they
have to have an exhibition and well I
don't think even Stalin oyd Marxism ever
quite known oh crap there's a new Legree
has a new look that's right but if I
want to open it up to the audience but
just before we do I want to ask you one
question on a different subject which is
something like the subject that that
Sherman Alexie might have been
addressing just to do with the future of
journalism in this in the new age we
find ourselves he clearly you said most
of your life as a working journalist and
we live in a moment when the environment
is being transformed yes I had dinner
about a year ago in Washington I seated
next to the publisher of The Washington
Post Katharine Weymouth and I asked her
because there were many stories about
the Washington Post begin in
difficulties and and I asked her how bad
was it and she said you know it's very
bad and she said to me that she had
recently been in Silicon Valley and
had gone to visit various of the leading
figures Yahoo Google etc and and she had
said to them
she said she asked them if you were me
what would you do and they had all of us
responded shut down the newspaper and
concentrate on the website which was
something which shocked her and which
clearly she didn't want to do but it was
an indication of a revolution coming now
the worry of course for many of us is
that the Internet has not yet shown
itself to be capable of supporting a
news gathering investigative project of
the kind that great newspapers have
supportive yes so if the print media die
and the internet fails immediately to
replace them
what are the prospects if you like for
the truth yes well one reason why nearly
couldn't make your kind invitation this
evening was with last night we had to
give the party at the white house
correspondents during the annual thing
where the press fawns too much on the
president and the president falls
slightly too much on the press and there
we all were in the Washington Hilton
ballroom and I thought you know it looks
thinner every year somehow and I could
add to what and Katherine was there she
came to our funny after that I was
thinking the Washington Times which is
the only rival to the Washington Post in
Washington now and which is a paper in
by the Reverend Sun Myung Moon of the
unification Church of that is very
nearly dead and will be a one newspaper
turn pretty soon I think last year
Seattle became a one newspaper town I
was astounded by that we have to say
said Lewis I think three or four Los
Angeles has been one for a bit and the
LA Times has gone down faster and
further than anyone would have believed
wherever one knows a bit of this story I
suppose but it's the speed of it that
impresses me and that's the production
end if you like the demand end I teach
writing and I've Drive some achieve
journalism and of my students I would
say that none now regularly take a
newspaper and that's
that's more or less in the demographic
as we say that's that's a death sentence
if if the habit of picking up a paper
and carrying it around with you or
taking it in the house in the morning is
gone among the young then you've more or
less set the clock but what are the
consequences of that well there so I
used to think what the positive thing is
that now if I have a bright young
student whose work is promising I don't
I can't just limit myself to saying to
them look I could probably introduce you
to someone in the newsroom in Chicago or
New York or it might be I'm gonna get
your your clips read you might be able
to bypass having to join the newspaper
guild or a union or anything like this
that you might get a break I've
considered them look you could you could
put up your own site you could publish
if you doomed to write your doom to
write and you could say okay okay I'll
put it up there and see if anyone wants
to come expose yourself directly and
that's been quite encouraging and I know
some people who've done rather well out
of it but here's what I think is the
danger it's partly the one you identify
it opens us to an era of so terrible
relativism where everyone's opinion is
as good as anyone elses you don't have
to earn it earn any credibility in a way
and pretty soon you'd have not just your
own opinions but your own choice of
facts and there wouldn't be a common
stock of reference which is by the way
are also problem in teaching literature
these days very difficult to find a book
that everyone has read but do you think
do you think that the things like iPad
on the Kindle are ways for newspapers to
survive yes I mean I think that the only
way they can survive but it won't
postpone the web postpone I don't think
people who weren't buying the New York
Times weren't buying it because they
couldn't get it on Kindle will now read
it because they can get it that way and
there's actually an easy proof of that I
think I was in them
I hate taxied TV don't you yes but one
particularly abject thing that happened
to me the other day in New York was it
was the New York Times ad clearly
pitch to the youth market in that
fawning way that older marketers talk to
young people or their people they
imagined to be young and say just get
the weekend edition you don't have to
sweat through all the news and use as
just it's all about sports and games and
music and theatre movies you love it and
the Washington Times Washington in
Washington Catherine's advertising in on
the radio in Washington is exactly the
same just take it for a couple of days a
week and read the fun stuff yeah you
don't think of us as a fuddy-duddy news
gathering we're not going to bore you
with lots of stories about you know
Afghanistan right like that
Downers everything is a turbulence so
the defeat has already been experienced
if you like it's a shame I was telling
someone before but has anyone seen the
paper with Michael Keaton feel great and
some research I'm a great great a great
movie I think about a day in the life of
a packed tabloid journalist in New York
he's obviously working for the post but
three papers are on his table in the
morning and his paper headline says your
headless body in topless bar and The
Daily News says something like you know
Ford to New York drop dead and the New
York Times says signs of swing to
moderation in Nepalese elections and he
throws the paper to the floor says these
pastors do anything to sell newspapers
that's over believing well on that point
medicine we have about 15 minutes or so
so if people have questions they'd like
to ask Christopher there's two
microphones there and there if you could
all use it and well OB but really him if
you could go to the microphones and take
it a turn yeah that's me
I love free speech but I'm worried about
FoxNews their influence that they have
so many viewers and they lie so much is
Jon Stewart enough you know and Colbert
how do we deal with them it's it's they
just make all the noise in the world
yeah I sometimes feel that I'm not as
judgmental about Fox as I might be but
it's because I was brought up in not
large part of the early part of my life
in in London where there's no pretense
of objectivity in journalism where you
know what you know what you're getting
you look at the newsstands and they're
ablaze with different papers that a
party oriented that are run by the in
the interests of certain proprietors not
least among them Keith Rupert Murdoch
who I last saw three o'clock this
morning by the French Embassy swimming
pool the wife half his age drop its
villages um looking by the way looking
by the way says we've got a lot of good
years left in it so I don't get shocked
so easily what I don't like is is a is a
paper or now that that pretends to be
objective it is not I think that's much
more of a danger yes um I'd like to ask
both of you what you think about there's
a there's been a relatively recent court
case about the Pledge of Allegiance in
which the plaintiff was was arguing that
it's a semi prayer you know especially
the part where it says under God and
trying to discourage and trying to make
it you know illegal to to force kids or
encourage kids to to say that during
school I wondered what you thought about
that well I know that I know the case
very well and I think mr. noodle who
brought it is at your slight pain in the
ass because instead of saying what he
should have said which is that the
Pledge of Allegiance was written and
promulgated and became popular and
well-loved word across America and the
1880s written by a socialist who was
trying to bring America Society back
together after the Civil War I was
trying to think of a pledge that anyone
in the country could recite whatever
their background he went on like that
virtually just the flag United States
America to the Republic which it stands
one nation indivisible the judge
liberty and justice for all this
beautiful in the McCarthy years the time
of the toad as another and the lillian
hellman news supported it was objected
by some big mouths that a flag Day
ceremony at Bacharach where Eisenhower
was president and was also present said
this pledge could be recited by a child
in Moscow word for word so how can you
make it so it couldn't be new problem
how could we have a pledge it couldn't
be recited Moscow shove in two words
where they don't belong destroy the
rhythm of the thing and and make it a
religious put in unto God so what you
want to say is no I'm for original
intent I'm a strict constructionist I
want the pledge back the way it was
most people wrote of impression that it
always had those words in and the
atheists are coming to take it out this
is stupid but of course it's flat-out
unconstitutional to ask a child to say
Allah God you may not do that First
Amendment is beautifully written
there's no wiggle room in it Congress
may make no law respecting an
establishment of religion thank you
Great Britain is having an election this
week and one of the candidates who seems
to be doing very well Nick Clegg of the
Liberal Democrats is a professed atheist
if he does very well in that election
does that mean something changing in
Britain something new that we don't have
in this country no England is very
different to the United States disregard
when Tony Blair who was who is deeply
religious was running for office he his
main kind of flight culture Alastair
Campbell said openly afterwards that
they deliberately played down his
religious beliefs because it would lose
the
now in England to be religious is to be
a flake and and who would vote for you
if that's what you you know like when I
remember when George W Bush was asked
early in his presidency and if he ever
consulted his father now that he was
president and he said pointing upwards
no because he had another father and to
whom you would refer now if he were to
say that in a British general election
he would be run out of town on a rail
yes I've always thought that actually
what George uni was saying is I brother
told you any farther than that one day
but mr. mr. young Mr Clegg as I think of
him which through my intern at the
nation magazine and of course I would
have hired him if he was a Muslim but
I'm glad to know that he still isn't a
believer in any hurry book and what
someone says is true in fact I could
have answered the last gentleman's
question by saying this maybe we should
just force all Americans to have prayer
in the schools because I don't know a
quicker way of bringing about the mass
production of eight years and among the
young then that's certainly the reason
for the secularization of British
society is the religion is compulsory in
English Scottish and Welsh schools it
has to be a certain Christian Protestant
kind and the Queen is the head of the
church as well as the state and the
Armed Forces which means on the moment
her heart ceases to beat it should never
happen but the moment that does happen
Prince Charles becomes the head of the
Church of England battier Muslim fancier
with no taste in women
and that's what you get through founding
a church on the family values of Henry
the age but I think the truth is I think
that in England is just not an issue
that nick clegg is not religious would
know would dream to bring it up against
it now they would rebound on them if
they do we'll see how well he actually
does all the day I mean I have I don't
know what you think Christopher I think
you could you could argue that in the
end people will swing back towards the
traditional two parties or that the the
anti-labor
sort of landslide has now gone so far
that they're actually going to do even
worse than the opinion polls suggested
but that actually we will have a
two-party state but blame party will be
the third party I think it's a three
party Society in case uncomfortably
within a two-party duopoly and every now
and then it it comes out again and it
did with Jeremy thought if you remember
in one point in the 70s and I think a
large part of the vote for mr. Cleg ISM
is a call for proportional
representation which now has to be
discussed seriously well we'll find out
on Thursday yes yes um I was really sad
to hear you say that when the Danes were
trying to get a muslim book for children
they didn't go to muslims and ask how do
we do it and that may have prevented the
cartoons from happening the cartoon
contest and the other thing is all the
talk about religion it's really the the
extremists the fanatics it's not the
mainstream anyone
I believe that's causing any
difficulties anywhere and I'd like your
opinion
well the question I mean you what you
say sounds persuasive and I don't know
by the way that they didn't go to
consult they must they would have done
Muslim authorities but the question
would be well which ones would those be
because their question number Imams in
Denmark but the ones who started there
about the cartoons are very extreme in
there well I'll come to use of that word
in a second and weren't going to I think
allow any discussion of the subject that
they did not themselves control so if
you went to one Muslim
authority you being all you be doing was
inviting yourself into a schismatic Rao
with between different factions of
Muslims which would have been a very
depressing way to introduce Jana
schoolchildren to the subject that's the
first thing the second thing is the word
fundamentalist or extreme has the
following difficulty for me either
there is a word of God or there is not
in my opinion there is not but if
someone says no you do you know what I
think God did speak at Sinai or did
speak at the baptism the Jordan or did
intervene to dictate checks the Prophet
Muhammad why does that make you a
fundamentalist and I think it's an
extraordinary thing to believe but if
you say no I don't really believe that
what you are is not not a fundamentalist
you're not religious fundamentalism says
there is God's word there is revelation
there has been revelation atheism is to
say there hasn't belief is what to split
that difference it can't be split yeah I
think we might even be able to discover
a slight difference between Christopher
me here right here's bring it on here's
a I mean maybe it's more apparent than
real but I think my view is that if
people are religious and gain from it
satisfaction nourishment solace whatever
it is my view is that's none of my
business when that comes into the public
arena and they and people of religious
belief try and force the values of that
belief onto me or onto the society in
which I live then it's my business and
and I have very strong views about
whether religion should be allowed into
that arena but in the privacy of one's
own home or one's own mind if one gains
comfort from a certain set of ideas
however
they might be that my view is just not
your business or my I prep the couldn't
agree more billets it's not in the
nature especially monotheism to let that
happen because they they're looking at
you going to hell they could they're not
allowed to do that they've s that canned
as opposed to anemia as opposed to save
you yes I'm not going to know they can't
really learn it's microbio keep saying
them if I thought there was a personal
God which of all the trouble to care
about me and supervise my movements and
and have a tender attitude towards me in
general and even promised me that I
would not croak I guess I have no idea
what it would be like to feel anything
so far us but I would suppose it would
make anyone it would make me happy you
know why doesn't him it doesn't mean him
happy at all the people who say they
believe this they can't be happy too I
believe it too and that's the cause of
the constant cultural metal so no I
don't want it why do I even know what
they believe so a church which was not
militant you think is not not really
there wouldn't be it wouldn't be the
church Judaism doesn't proselytize well
except among Jews much it doesn't
anymore yeah well it also it doesn't say
the Messiah has already come that says
it has its advantages there too yes
hi yeah my question is about engagement
and maybe the role for engagement
there's been a lot of discussion about
free speech and advocating it and
standing up for it but um I live in
Woking China and often when artists or
musicians writers abroad protest China
it does make it harder for people
working in the system so I Swan to see
your thoughts on the balance between
engagement and protest I guess well you
keep hearing it I suppose it must
sometimes be true but if everyone kept
quiet about a certain country or a
certain stage and didn't get give its
government the impression that
foreigners were intervening and so on
that that it might make life easier for
the local the chamber sort of dissident
you know one is often told that we're
always told for example that Iranians
done welcome support
for their efforts from outsiders because
they they can then be identified or even
criminalized with with that so right up
again as long as the regime itself stays
out of my life but the Iranians won't do
that they won't let me think Oh will I
don't care what happens in Iran on the
contrary they say they want to export
people to kill Salman people to
overthrow the democracy of Lebanon
people to blow up the Jewish Community
Center in Buenos are as we know the
names of the people who've been doing
this in Tehran and to have an
off-the-record nuclear program well I'm
sorry and this is another internal
affair and I don't have a single human
rights question since you mentioned your
domicile Burma the are Zimbabwe Iran
with just those three for now you try
and get anything done about those a poor
dead North Korea he's appalling really
appalling regime and you find that
they're protected by a Chinese guarantee
of the United Nations and in Sudan
therefore that's not China wants to buy
all their oil it's going to it means I'm
gives them all their all their weapons
you cannot address major human rights
drama in the world now without coming
against coming up against Chinese power
on the on the wrong side I'm sorry this
is not their internal affair also add to
that you know if you look at the
experience of pen pen American Center I
would say two things
every time that pen has supported a
writer in difficulties or arrests in
whatever in whatever country we have
heard back from those writers that it
was enormous ly valuable to them to know
that their case was being seen by the
rest of the world and that they gained
great strength and nourishment from the
fact that their case was being
highlighted so certainly in the cases of
those writers who have been on the front
line to them it has mattered a great
deal that their case
was was giving provenance
but there's another thing which is if
you look at the these so-called awards
that pen gives every year two writers
work which would actually obviously
those are writers in jail so the award
is a way of highlighting their plight
there is an enormous Lehigh percentage
which i think is somewhere on 90% of
those writers being released from jail
within a six month period and it is
because of its grand character and
tyranny does not like publicity and it
is one of the curious weaknesses of
tyrants that they want to be liked and
if you could show them that they are not
liked and actually that the world takes
their [ __ ] because what what they're
doing to that writer or those writers
it's sometimes easier for them to
release those writers and stop getting
that kind of back of listing if this has
been our experience in country after
country for many many years though so
good so I would say about the publicity
that on the one hand it gives strength
to the good guys and on the other hand
it very often discomforts the bad guys
so much that they actually change their
baby yes yes I was wondering if you
could give specific examples of great
literary novels that are now being
censored Muslim on societies and very
sympathetic about Satanic Verses
children under balawi god dies by the
nile and so forth but is there anything
right now and if so would it be as hard
that's doing it is it Saudi Arabia is it
Iran and could you give the name of the
book and the author well the most famous
book that is bowdlerized in every single
Muslim country is not published
unexpurgated in a single Muslim country
at this point is the 1001 nights the
Arabian night in the Arabian Nights the
most famous book in the history of our
obliterator cannot be published
uncensored in any arab country why
because it's full of not events
there's a lot of sex in the Arabian
Nights and oddly there's very little
religion you know God doesn't make many
appearances in the Arabian Nights but
men and women having a great deal of sex
make a lot of appearances and so there
it is only the most famous work in the
history of the literature is the one
being censored Iran has to authorize the
publication of novels by board of
censors every year they have been years
I don't know if this is one of them but
there have been years recently where not
a single novel has been approved for
publication
so no novels have been published that
where the low novels were deemed worthy
of publication so the censorship wizard
is at a very extreme level it's also the
Matthew Polly announcement of under
development it's help you should look up
the armed development report which was
produced under the auspices of my friend
Clovis luck soon used to be the head of
the Arab League and a panel of other
regional intellectuals and writers on
the sheer dearth of literary material
known as it was a melee of censorship of
the failure to publish or translate
Greece translates more books into out of
other languages into Greek every year
then the whole Arab world does in its
entire language it's just it's a matter
the unavailability of things that it's
cultural starvation rather than singling
out of a book for censorship the early
book I know about the concentrate my
minds I've just written the introduction
to its anniversary edition is animal
farm which is banned in all Muslim
countries not just because of the pigs
who after all if you remember don't come
that well out of the book yet because
certainly certainly in your on where
I've been involved in an attempt to
gather to get a pirate edition going a
possibly smuggle back into Persia it's
because it's about a revolution betrayed
it's much more political okay we're out
of time so if you could please ask a
quick question and could forgive really
quick answer that we deserve sorry okay
um you mentioned vaclav havel earlier
who as you know was a playwright before
he became the press
I'm often wondered what a government
composed of writers would look like and
if art and politics necessarily has to
be independent in a free society so I
was just wondering on if you think that
would necessarily be detrimental and
what that would look like Salman for
president mr. mr. president I can just I
have called him that when he was
president and pleasure thought it would
be the worst possible idea in the
Republican says that where that really
would be terrible that'd be the worst
kind of tyranny of the picture third she
should probably be that when what
examples do we have that could be the
least bit encouraging yeah well some
countries have done very well by making
their writers into ambassadors yeah
George Surfaris was a brilliant
ambassador Carlos Fuentes cars Fuentes
okay Edwards was a great diplomat Diego
well we had a near miss with Mario
Vargas Llosa
yes but had bats Lahav oh I'm not
applied for the job however was the best
and Georgie Conrad was offered the
presidency of Hungary after the collapse
of communism but but the author of
anti-politics Andres other wonderful
books but he said no I think he's partly
cuz he thought the first independent
president of Hungary I mean president of
independent hungry should not be a Jew
rather a rather arcane a reservation but
perhaps a good one
in the circumstances okay well no I
think I think I think people should be
elected okay I think children really I
think on behalf of Penn we have to offer
a big vote of thanks to Christopher
Hitchens
Christopher Hitchens is a contributing
editor at Vanity Fair magazine and a
professor of Liberal Studies at the new
school in New York City his books
include
why Orwell matters God is not great
and the forthcoming memoir hitch 22 for
more information visit Penn org every
weekend sees Bantu spoke to